hi everyone in this video I will talk
about neuron a structural and functional
unit of our brain so this is the cover
video for my whole playlist where I
would discuss about several properties
of the neuron to a functional circuit
and also describe some aspect of pren
physiology now here is our very
well-known diagram for neuro and this
diagram we are very familiar with we
have seen this diagram from our school
and college level textbooks so just to
describe this diagram in you have a lot
of dendrites at this end and dendrites
are branches of the neuron and in the
cell body it is actually the central hub
of all sort of synthesis or other stuff
and axon is the terminal through which
the neuronal impulse the electrical
impulse travels but this diagram is
pretty old this kind of model is pretty
old so let's just reject this concept
because earlier in 1919 1906 camellia
Corgi and Santiago Ramon Iike hawk kept
their Nobel Prize to describe several
aspects of the neuronal morphology and
from Santiago Ramon Iike Hal's drawing
you can clearly see that neuron comes in
several different vivid mythologies then
why should should we restrict ourselves
to that one textbook image that's why
here is the image of gfp-tagged neurons
of the cerebral cortex look how
beautiful they look like so let's just
change our view to a view like this so
these are typical pyramidal neurons of
the self
corvex now if we zoom in we see at any
point of time a neuron is receiving
inputs from quite a lot of other neurons
and when the neuron gets the impulses it
is getting processed by the postsynaptic
neuron here you can see the junction
between the neurons are called synapses
so what happens at the synapses at the
synapses there are voltage-gated calcium
channels here in green and also in the
postsynaptic membrane there are
receptors which are basically degan
gated ion channels which opens or closed
and when ligand binds and closes
wounding and is not bound so these red
colored dots represents the
neurotransmitters so when our action
potential reaches the nerve terminal
there is rapid influx of calcium and
ultimately it leads to neurotransmitter
release
in a synaptic gift and the new
transmitter binds to the post synapse
and thereby causing depolarization in
the post synapse
now when the depolarization which is a
threshold the postsynaptic neuron fires
another action potential now have you
ever wondered why does our nervous
system have to all need a synapse if it
need to transfer information it can use
only one long cable why it need a
synapse a possible answer could be for
better regulatory mechanisms the synapse
at the places where huge regulatory
mechanisms takes place and synapse are
pretty interesting because we
environmental experiences and
environmental exposure the synapses
could change the strength the weight of
the synapses could change so that
synapses are very dynamic in nature and
also it's a puzzle that how action
potential and release
vesicles all these things I would be
discussing in my subsequent videos now
this is a typical cell which has a
nucleus endoplasmic reticulum Golgi
mitochondria other cell organelles etc
neurons from a sylvia logical aspect
have that all of those but how neural is
different from a normal cell
from a cell biological aspect the
function from a functional aspect neuron
is pretty different from a normal cell
think about this a neuron synthesize
some amount of protein and these
proteins are marked by this red this
green yellow boxes and these protein
need to be specifically delivered to
this branch or let's say this branch so
neuron has to devise a way by which it
can send this to this specific power
branch how difficult this task could be
because one neuron could have thousands
of branches and a more on the thousands
of branches there could be 10,000
synapses so this task is incredibly
difficult but still neuron can perform
this kind of task pretty efficiently so
this is a mystery in neuroscience how
this kind of differential transport
happens so this kind of specialized
properties of neurons differentiate them
from a normal cell now neuron doesn't
stay in isolation in Steve Newlin's are
part of a functional circuit you don't
take input from the environment or from
other different neurons process them to
give rise to an output so question is
time here on our new long Canon code for
several different sensory modalities
like olfaction like vision like auditory
cues or like specific like specific
touch etc now neuron you
specific firing patterns sometimes to
code for information for example this
muon uses this kind of firing pattern
maybe for gun this kind of firing
pattern could be for one kind of
stimulus maybe it can use another firing
pattern for another kind of stimulus or
for a different intensity of the same
stiffness also it can use a different
bursting regime to encode an information
neuron can code information by changing
the fire unit or changing the firing
frequency or changing the interspike
interval all these changes could lead to
a functional change that could code a
different information altogether so
these are very interesting aspect how
neuron can code for several
functionalities in my subsequent videos
I will be talking about all these things
in details now neuron is different from
other cells in many aspects one of the
important aspect is that neurons
membrane is decorated with several
different ion channels these ion
channels comprise of voltage-gated
sodium channel voltage-gated potassium
channel some leak
potassium channels and also sodium
potassium heart exchange pump so so many
ion channels only found in neurons and
these are channels are several different
several different type and also they
have different properties to play for
example a mammalian neuron has hundreds
of different voltage-gated potassium
several different voltage-gated
potassium channel and also different
varieties of lead potassium channel each
of that give rise to a specific coding
function now you will use different
coding scheme for propagation of the
information definitely which uses action
potential action potential is a mode of
propagation of information which is
all-or-none in
major that means it's a binary way of
transforming information apart from that
you don't use a graded potential for
transforming for propagating the
information and graded potential is also
very important like action potential
because credit potential can give rise
to specific advantages for a functional
circuit to code information all these
things I would be discussing in my
subsequent videos also neuronal membrane
could be modeled like an RC circuit
where a portion of the membrane could be
modeled as a combination of capacitor
and resistor the differential charges in
the two side of the neuronal membrane
works like a parallel plate of a
capacitor and the phospholipid bilayer
is just like a dielectric and several
ion channels are just like conductances
or they work like a resistor so that is
how neuronal membrane is very different
and could be model like a circuit as new
could be model like a circuit functional
RC circuit has differential operation
paradigm some could work as a
differentiator some could work as an
integrator a functional neuron in a
circuit also has this kind of different
operational paradigm which I will be
discussing later
now neurons are not only cells their
sales with specialized properties they
constitute a functional Network which
ultimately forms our brain I hope you
enjoyed this video if you liked my video
give it a quick thumbs up don't forget
to Like share and subscribe and please
watch the subsequent videos to gain
better knowledge in neurobiology thank
you